>>> TURNING TO POST-ROE AMERICA
IN OUR POLITICS LEAD AND THE
PUSH TO CODIFY INTO LAW POSSIBLY
VULNERABLE RIGHTS THAT THE
SUPREME COURT HAD PREVIOUSLY
AFFIRMED SUCH AS THE RIGHT OF
SAME-SEX COUPLES TO GET MARRIED.
SHORTLY AFTER THE HOUSE PASSED A
BILL THAT WOULD HAVE AFFORDED
SUCH PROTECTIONS TO LGBTQ
COUPLES EARLIER THIS WEEK,
REPORTERS CAUGHT UP WITH MARCO
RUBIO AS HE WAS GETTING ON AN
ELEVATOR TO FIND OUT HOW HE WAS
GOING TO VOTE.
RUBIO WHO IS UP FOR RE-ELECTION
THIS YEAR, TOLD JOURNALISTS THE
BILL WAS NOTHING MORE THAN A
STUPID WASTE OF TIME.
THOSE REMARKS AS HE WAS GETTING
ON AN ELEVATOR WITH THE FIRST
OPENLY GAY SENATOR EVER ELECTED
TO CONGRESS, WISCONSIN DEMOCRAT
TAMMY BALDWIN, AND SENATOR
BALDWIN JOINS US NOW.
SENATOR, WHAT DID YOU SAY WHEN
HE GOT ON THE ELEVATOR?
>> WELL, OF COURSE, I HAD TO
MAKE AN ELEVATOR PITCH, RIGHT?
I ONLY HAD A SHORT TIME, BUT HE
WAS KIND OF SHOCKED TO SEE ME
STANDING THERE AFTER TALKING
WITH YOUR REPORTER.
AND I REALLY DID TALK ABOUT WHY
IT'S NEEDED AT THIS POINT IN
TIME AND WHY IT'S NOT A WASTE OF
TIME TO THE MANY GAY AND
INTERRATIONAL COUPLES THAT LIVE
IN FLORIDA.
AND HE'S OBVIOUSLY NOT
CONVINCED, BUT I SAID, WE'LL BE
TALKING.
BUT AS YOU KNOW, I AM WORKING
VERY HARD TO IDENTIFY A 60-VOTE
MAJORITY IN ORDER TO PASS THIS
LEGISLATION, TO SAFEGUARD THESE
RIGHTS.
AND I'M GOING TO CONTINUE DOING
THAT JOB.
>> SO IT SOUNDS AS THOUGH EVEN
THOUGH HE HAD JUST SAID A VOTE
ON WHETHER OR NOT YOU CAN
LEGALLY GET MARRIED TO WHOEVER
YOU WANT, EVEN THOUGH HE SAID
THAT IN YOUR PRESENCE WAS A
STUPID WASTE OF TIME, IT SOUNDS
LIKE YOUR APPROACH TO HIM WAS
NOT ONE OF ANGER BUT ONE OF
REASON.
IS THAT -- AM I READING YOU
CORRECTLY?
>> YES.
SO ONCE THE SUPREME COURT
DECIDED IN THE DOBBS CASE THAT
THE CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT TO
PRIVACY NO LONGER EXISTS, AND
WHEN JUSTICE CLARENCE THOMAS
WENT A BIT FURTHER IN SAYING
THIS COURT SHOULD REVISIT ALL
THE CASES DECIDED UNDER SIMILAR
CONSTITUTIONAL ARGUMENTS, IT PUT
IN JEOPARDY OUR RIGHT TO ACCESS
CONTRACEPTION.
IT PUT IN JEOPARDY SAME-SEX
MARRIAGE, FRANKLY INTERRACIAL
MARRIAGE AND OTHER RIGHTS THAT
HAVE BEEN DECIDED, AGAIN, UNDER
THE SAME CONSTITUTIONAL
CONSTRUCT.
AND SO IT'S VERY IMPORTANT THAT
WE PASS LEGISLATION TO SAFEGUARD
THE RIGHT OF MARRIAGE EQUALITY
AND ACCESS TO CONTRACEPTION, ET
CETERA.
THE HOUSE IS DOING JUST THAT.
I WANT THE SENATE TO JOIN THE
HOUSE IN THEIR BOLD BIPARTISAN
ACTION LAST TUESDAY.
I WANT THE SENATE TO DO THAT AS
SOON AS POSSIBLE.
>> SO AS YOU KNOW, WE HAVE
DEMOCRATS AND REPUBLICANS,
LIBERALS AND CONSERVATIVES ON
"THE LEAD," AND I JUST, TO TELL
YOU WHAT A CONSERVATIVE OR A
REPUBLICAN MIGHT SAY IN RESPONSE
TO WHAT YOU JUST SAID, THEY
WOULD SAY FIRST OF ALL, YES,
CLARENCE THOMAS WROTE THAT, BUT
SAMUEL ALITO WHO WROTE THE DOBBS
OPINION, SAID THAT BASICALLY
CLARENCE THOMAS IS WRONG.
WE'RE FOUGHT GOING TO REVISIT
ALL THOSE CASES.
SO THAT'S ONE.
THAT THIS ISSUE, DOBBS, IS
DIFFERENT BECAUSE IT'S ISSUES OF
LIFE AS OPPOSED TO THE OTHER
THINGS, CONTRACEPTION, SODOMY,
AND SAME-SEX MARRIAGE.
AND SECOND, YOU BROUGHT UP
INTERRACIAL MARRIAGE, LOVERING
V. VIRGINIA, WHICH CLARENCE
THOMAS WHO IS MARRIED TO A WHITE
WOMAN, DID NOT BRING UP.
THEIR BASIC ARGUMENT IS
DEMOCRATS ARE JUST DOING THIS TO
SCARE PEOPLE, TO TRY TO GET
THEIR VOTERS TO THE POLLS.
THIS IS NOT A REAL THREAT.
>> WELL, THIS ISN'T A PARTISAN
ISSUE AT ALL.
AND IN FACT, THAT'S WHY I FEEL
VERY HOPEFUL THAT WE WILL HAVE
MORE THAN 60 VOTES IN ORDER TO
CODIFY THE RESPECT FOR MARRIAGE
ACT.
BUT I CAN TELL YOU THAT A CASE
AS SIGNIFICANT AS THE
OVERTURNING OF ROE V. WADE IN
DOBBS, THAT OVERTURNS 49 YEARS
OF PRECEDENT.
WOMEN IN AMERICA HAVE LESS
FREEDOM TODAY THAN THEIR MOTHERS
AND GRANDMOTHERS HAD.
AND THERE HAS BEEN MUCH WRITTEN
ALREADY ABOUT THE VULNERABILITY
OF OTHER RIGHTS THAT WERE
DECIDED IN THE SAME MANNER AS
THE COURT APPROACHED DOBBS.
AND SO THERE IS A LOT OF FEAR.
THERE'S A LOT OF -- THERE'S
CERTAINLY FULL UNDERSTANDING
THAT WERE IT NOT FOR THE
OBERGEFELL DECISION, WHICH
CREATED MARRIAGE EQUALITY IN THE
U.S., THAT THERE ARE MANY STATES
THAT WOULDN'T HAVE THAT RIGHT.
AND SO THIS IS SIMPLY A BILL TO
SAY THAT THE FULL FAITH AND
CREDIT OF THE UNITED STATES WILL
BE PLACED IN THE LEGAL
ENACTMENTS OF OTHER STATES.
AND IT WILL REQUIRE RECOGNITION,
AND IT'S A VERY IMPORTANT STEP
FORWARD.
AND WE CAN'T FORGET, IT WASN'T
SO LONG AGO THAT WE WERE STILL
WORKING TO TRY TO LEGISLATE
MARRIAGE EQUALITY.
>> RIGHT.
>> AND MARRIAGE IS SOMETHING
THAT CONFERS HUNDREDS OF RIGHTS
AND RESPONSIBILITIES.
>> YEAH.
>> THINGS LIKE BEING ABLE TO
VISIT YOUR SPOUSE IN THE
HOSPITAL IF THEY'RE ILL VERSUS
BEING VIEWED AS A LEGAL
STRANGER.
AND SO THESE ARE REAL LIFE
THINGS THAT WE NEED TO FIGHT
FOR.
>> I KNOW YOUR FELLOW WISCONSIN
SENATOR RON JOHNSON JUST
ANNOUNCED LA NIGHT IF THE BILL
COMES UP, HE WILL VOTE IN
SUPPORT OF IT, BUT MY
UNDERSTANDING IS RIGHT NOW, YOU
NEED TEN REPUBLICANS.
AND YOU ONLY HAVE FIVE.
IS THAT RIGHT?
>> I THINK THERE'S A NUMBER OF
FOLKS WHO ARE CHOOSING TO MAKE
THEIR ANNOUNCEMENT ON THEIR OWN
TIME.
I HAVE HAD SOME ENCOURAGING
CONVERSATIONS WHERE WE STARTED
THE CONVERSATION, THEY'RE GOING
TO READ THE BILL, WE'LL TALK
EITHER LATER THIS WEEKEND OR
EARLY NEXT WEEK.
BUT I THINK WE'RE GETTING REALLY
CLOSE.
>> ALL RIGHT, DEMOCRAT FROM
WISC